[Music]
coach manager of the year sponsored by
Bayside signs and display Phil shears
its Newton Abbot water polo coach Phil
shears gives up many hours a week to
Train the under-15 under-17 and ladies
squads successfully leading Newton Abbot
water polo under 15 girls to win the
2017 national championships Phil
compounded this success by winning the
2018 national championships with the
under-16 girls team this achievement is
the result of many hours of dedication
and commitment as matches take place all
over the country with Newton bat ladies
team Phil on the 2017 Devon Knockout Cup
and the 2017-18 Devon ladies league
beating Devonport and Exeter Phil is a
much appreciated highly respected coach
throughout the County region and
nationally
Ryan Boogaard Ryan's reputation brings
lots of members to Bobbie Tracy Tennis
Club
especially juniors and he regularly
coaches around 110 junior members age 4
to 16 which is exceptional for a club of
this size this is due to Ryan's hard
work creating links to a range of
primary schools in the area as well as
Coons Head Academy this has also brought
success to the club with divisional
titles individual honors and gold medals
Ryan has also established holiday camps
and fitness sessions as well as coaching
Devon ladies over 50s to further enhance
the reach of the community
his dedication commitment and enthusiasm
to tennis coaching in the club is
outstanding and he is adding a lot of
value to all ages of the community in
Bobbie Tracy Sarah Leakey and James
Gilbert James and Sarah coach underwater
hockey jointly running the southwest
under 12 team Sarah takes on the
manager's role and keeps the team
organized focused and motivated whilst
supporting James and coaching under the
command of Sarah and James the under 12
team of won two national championships
and the National regions championships
plus winning numerous local matches
Sarah and James are driven and
competitive but teaching the kids the
healthy side of competition and great
sportsmanship Sarah and James always
have positive feedback for their players
and other teams celebrating every
success and encouraging improvement
you
you